tell me a story about meeting Matt Damon
and Ben Affleck for the first time we're
at Paramount Pictures I think this is
1992 for they called it the pizza party
for School ties and I met Ben Matt
Reynold batinkoff Anthony Rapp Andrew
Lowry and the cast of of uh School Ties
which is such an awesome movie it was a
amazing cast and an amazing experience
um okay uh a funny story about one of my
favorite movies and I'm so not alone on
this you're in the breakup oh God
the brother Brothers
Lucas garbowski
when I walked in as Looper skarboski you
know into the club and I started talking
to the girl the whole crew was like that
is so filthy uh-huh just said to that
girl
they're like well you said it though and
I was like okay I said it like and then
they found out later that I used to
actually say that
well take a look at that